I'm Joanna and I
believe that creating
a functional Android app
and a great Android app
are two different things,
but only one of them
will help you engage
and delight users.
And that's why Udacity
partnered with Google
to produce Advanced Android App
Development, which explains how
to make an app stand out
with the kind of polish that
leads to success in
the Google Play store.
Students will learn how
to improve the appeal
and speed of their app's
UI, with material design
features and helpful
libraries, as well as
how to widen their audience
and reach all sorts of users
with simple localization
and accessibility updates.
They'll also learn how to
expand their apps functionality
by building an app
widget and integrating
with Google Cloud Messaging for
efficient server and network
use.
So check it out.
It's going to be awesome.